forza signori benvenuti questo
nuovissimo video su fonda io sono quello
che fa io spogliare e che vince extra
con spero che i miei spettacolo oggi
almeno non sappiamo ragazzi l'importante
è provarci allora alessio e dopo ragazzi
che sto provando a capire come
migliorare nella prima partita perché
l'obiettivo overnight hausen sarebbe
quello di fare tutte le partite perfette
cioè arrivare primo in tutte le partite
nella prima è sempre un casino ragazzi
perché purtroppo c'è sempre al discorso
del fatto che ci sono 40 players un
action quindi puoi fare le cose fino a
un certo punto l'ex pro non arriverò mai
il primo perché alla fine per arrivare
primo quadri di sfruttare al meglio
anche le lancette cosa io non faccio
così ma che comunque perfetto non passo
neanche nel centro perché tanto non
ormai non era arrivare primo l'obiettivo
il problema è che man mano che la season
va avanti la gente si stila sempre di
più diventano sempre tutti i più forti
non che me ne freghi qualcosa però
importante vincerà il quali file led blu
è la prima ce la siamo tolta dai preti
perfetto e che tanto è sempre quella che
mi rompere più le scatole di tutte mi di
via fuori dalle palle
va bene così daisy raga penso di ormai
averla mascherata totalmente quindi
quando è sceso non regga contento ecco
infatti un cazzo allora due è visto già
ripreso da imi e le mie cagate che ho
detto all'inizio ko perfetto ragazzi
sempre al centro per vedere dove cadono
gli prevedendo che cadono gli altri
cerchi ragazzi importante perché dal
centro potete porco demonio chaffeur mai
e vabbè dal 100 potete vedere che culo e
culo totale dal centro potete vedere
tutto quello che succede
potete agire molto più in fretta quindi
rimanete al centro
distribuitevi come dico sempre perché
ormai allo sfinimento l'ho detto metà
squadra l'anno parte e nola preso lui
porco demonio dicevo metà squadra una
parte ragazzi e metà squadra va fango la
sopaf artigiani punti almeno una decina
tutti preso anche quello porco demonio
da 5 eccolo oggi con loro ce l'ha fatta
l'ho preso ho preso due oro ragazzi ce
va beh dai da da una parte ragazzi metà
dall'altra
se siete in gruppo con qualcuno e state
parlando all'ossola telefono soddisfi
comunque state giocando insieme con il
vostro amico fate sì che uno si erano a
farne una dall'altra sempre almeno
coprite per bene le due i due emisferi
della mappa come parlo bene ragazzi
siete sicuri che almeno una parte una
dall'altra perché alle volte rimangono
tutti da una parte ed è uno schifo
comunque vabbè ho fatto un sacco di
punti sono orgoglioso 15 qualificati
potrebbe uscire ex crumble ragazzi
perché esce sempre ultimamente doblò
parti con un detto avrei preferito una
materia non devastarlo nell idea va bene
anche due parti il problema di bloc
party e che è diventato un disastro ogni
volta c'è il po di collision che ti
fotte la partita non è non devo avere il
problema delle degli ostacoli ma della
della gente che mi viene addosso che non
è capace e ci devo rimettere io alla
fine quindi dipende tutto da quello
regala va bene per adesso tutto in
regola rai a tutto in regola sono
saltato di un chilometro ok questa è la
parte che va accumula ormai di blu party
dipende solo ed unicamente da quanto la
gente ti viene addosso o meno essendo in
15 ce n'è veramente poca
ok 9 c'era poca stiamo per ogni tanto
diventa infattibile quindi quanti siamo
rimasti ragazzi finali in 89
cerasti 9 fantastico
va bene hexagon per favore se esce col
monte in deve andarmi a quello che mi
metta spero vi mette davanti se no che
vedono di oggi anche anche jean showdown
va bene anche jobson va bene exa colpa
però bene a venezia non va bene sto
ragazzi sono i nove posso fare il trick
non lo faccio non lo faccio perché non
me la sento me la sono giocata ponderata
tutta la pa e poi c'è questo cuore mi
fissa la prima non lo faccio non voglio
strappare la capra in nove è ormai in
ogni intenzione ritar ci ho ripensato
alla fine ma ormai sono fuori taggio o
parto subito niente a mi sa che qualcuno
ha fatto che ho fatto bene a non andare
mi sa che qualcuno la fattoria voluta di
vita la stessa idea il problema sapete
quale i ragazzi che se qualcuno fa il
trip che volevo fare io di andare
sull'ultima piattaforma e di levare
l'ultima piattaforma se qualcuno fa quel
click con voi avete perso tutto il
rumore perché all'ultima piattaforma
correte tutti e due e non c'è niente da
fare quindi
ma a quel punto è meglio evitare con
quello ho fatto quasi tutta la
piattaforma gialla
niente male francesco avevano un po di
roba questo solito non ci voglio credere
non ci voglio barca vacca credere come
ho fatto a cadere
no ragazzi ho fatto una cagata dove
voleva nella piattaforma quello di sotto
perché la troppo fuori niente niente sto
facendo pagare o il più brutto extra con
che abbia mai visto
cioè che abbia mai fatto perché visto
sempre uguali o meno male che tutto
quello che prima non avevo messo ancor
prima avevo giocato da schifo
cioè ragazzi questo non è per niente un
mio hexagon mamma mia come l'ho giocata
male però va beh forse riesco nonostante
le cagate che ho fatto forse sta tenerla
se mi impegno a
ma cosa c'è oggi le gambe di burro cioè
non riesco a calcolare la distanza oggi
io faccio schifo sporca ma è rimasto
solo lui ti prego no no ti prego
[Musica]
cosa che è bucio de culo
no ragazzi non ragazzi no io veramente
non guarda guarda avevo così fatto una
partita perfetta poi ti ho mio ogni
tanto le botte di culo ma guarda che è
veramente incredibile ragazzi questa
cosa ci voglio credere
totalmente insensata mi sono buttato
completamente nel vuoto e come il fatto
a voi the doors va bene dai facciamo sta
roba
non ho visto la porta non ho visto a
porta aveva niente altro non l'avevano
mai prima indoor da sci non può arrivare
più cern e non con la mia tattica
io li seguono gli altri l'udc ei papà la
propone delle stesse sua rivale primo
facciamo questa tattica
sono partito molto indietro vi la vedo
proprio dura però proviamo normale
normale o male non male
non male ha preso un botto di posizione
i ragazzi però sono fuso il martello ma
d'ora vede il suo martello
porca vacca questo aggiornamento ragazzi
mi stanno fottendo il cervello mi ero
dimenticato nel martello che comunque
molti utilizzano per arrivare alla fine
io non sono falle vista cosa perché se
io uso il martello in genere e proprio
perché sono completamente disperato nel
senso sparami alla fine ecco infatti
questo ha preso una testata mondiale
allora teoricamente un bel freaks cinesi
ma che culo ragazzi oggi oggi mi devono
graziare subsidenza e la mia mappa
preferita in assoluto e niente ragazzi
come prima che vi dovessero tutti qua
però siamo in quattro non so quanti sono
d'altra parte secondo me si deve
spostare facendo cagare misura e la
prima partita in da un bolide no pesa fi
o me l'ha dato me l'ha dato me l'ha dato
non è vero che bug infinito tempismo 0
ma basta ma perché se cerchi così non lo
sai che faccio
nove ragazzi cosa faccio entrarvi a
ombra cos'è mida cerchi non ci sono
entrato io libera dato lo stesso
dovrebbe fa niente
vincevamo uguale senza i miei barche
però com'è possibile che mi abbia dato
sul cerchio bank su bug ma fa niente
andiamo avanti
mexes riise con 12 potrebbe essere o tik
tok hun ciancio da un lietamente finale
ok
meno male che giace dow tra l'altro e
non fa il mondo facciamola bene ragazzi
per farla al meglio vorrei che si
sovrapponessero due piattaforme vicine
in modo tale da avere più spazio nel
caso dovessero sono apparsi della gente
che io chiamo sempre lancette ragazzino
mi vien da pensare questa roba un
orologio qualcuno l'avrà fatto un
orologio così a tema polgai se lo compro
subito sto avendo veramente un tempismo
orribile vi devo svegliare un attimo
perché come partita sta andando male
cioè sono partito che ho beccato votato
due facciate sulla lancetta non ho fatto
ancora niente
ok il progetto mamma mia ho rischiato
come la morte qua ragazzi non sapevo se
andare indietro se andare verso la
lancetta ma ho rischiato non dovevo fare
così è andata anche bene ok che guarda
indietro per forza addosso come di tutti
la ragazzi siamo in 56 am inn 61 cadete
maledetti c'è uno che devo che perfetto
una caduta c'è uno che tiene fermo gli
altri termini eccola e crovetti sente
schifoso mori come t no ragazzi se se io
perdo per una foto kodo ricascato ma te
lo meriti perché fai schifo perché fai
schifo te lo meriti
maledizione la gente che grava hanno un
girone dell'inferno aiuta makadi porca
vacca quanto siamo ragazzi quanto sta
durando sta roba
ca di piccione maledetto non lo tengo
per me perché sono ok lo sapevo
allora allora fatevi spiegare sta roba
io l'ho ottenuto lui mi ha tenuto dopo
ci sono tutti insieme però son riuscito
a saltare prima
ecco è la prima volta che vinco usando
la tattica chi generi odio cioè
aggravare la già in sé un grammo mai
nessuno ragazzi dai ragazzi nei due
vittorie oggi ce l'abbiano spero che vi
sia piaciuto siamo quasi a fine season
quindi sto gustando un po agli episodi
di volgare per questo motivo perché alla
fine si sono quindi ne vedete 3 ne
vedrete 3 anche la prossima settimana
però io mi sia piaciuto e ci vediamo
ancora domani che lunedì con un'altra
bisogno di paul guys were agazzi
[Musica]